hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch from forever red 3000 I love
you and me and the Russians 3000 we're
gonna watch the vengers end game anime
opening three attack on titan this is a
top reward to your request from a new
patron named matthew Cronenberg it's
Cronin I don't know how this youtuber
got this song to be included this video
might get blocked worldwide best case
scenario it's just hit with includes
copyrighted content this attack on Titan
theme I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who has followed us at our
patreon page over there we do not hit or
spit on our dogs we do weekly Q&A z' TV
show reaction stream alongs for many
shows those are Cobra Kai season 2
haunting and Hell House to Gotham all
the stranger things season 3 agents of
shield several shows have stream belongs
and reaction highlights included so you
get two versions those are attack on
Titan Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
season 1 a one-punch man my hero
academia movie included as well janja
startup Death Note I just started up
code geass start up Hunter x Hunter that
shows getting good and we're on season 3
now Supernatural head on over to our
patreon page Hey
[Music]
I recognize that
[Music]
I like how hats use food like this whole
thing
[Music]
oh this is great this is so much like it
[Music]
sweetie shot yeah they get all the
character running to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you never knew what they were saying all
the chip
you gotta look up some translation it's
totally spoiling it wow this is really
well hi
[Applause]
[Applause]
Marvel Studios movie well cut well
edited everyone got to subscribe to this
guy right away yeah yeah and then you
got to cut together like a last time on
reel of all the Avengers movies just
plays right after this before we get
into this episode of endgame
that's very funny yes cuz it's an
amazing well I saw some similarities
because I've watched Adriel oh yeah I
saw so many similarities because I have
scrubbed episodes on net I mean like the
delayed explosion a reaction like what
the song were when you're first watching
this Avengers hang game one you're
thinking Oh where's the music there it
is after the explosion and the season
three part two opener has that as well
none of the shots necessarily are
representative that are like similar
angles so much to some they fit the mood
in the tone and the breathing room of
certain angles that they show here are
certain moments they chose to capture
because they're both you know centering
around a bunch of desperate people in
the midst of a big scale battle so I
feel like there's a bunch of similarity
you can already use there yeah because
in season three part two half of that
section revolves around this one
specific battle so it actually made
sense to pull from endgame and revolve
this whole opening around this one
specific battle yeah so I thought that
was pretty neat and then also of course
like at the very end of this that quick
little flashy opacity montage that
happen at the end
oh yeah the biggest stylistic things to
me were the colors those transitional
wipe things they would do like it's a
bunch of frames moving up really fast
and then yeah that montage at the very
end where it's like super fast it seemed
like those were the main things you
could port over and then the rest of it
was you know yeah matching the mood yeah
which I thought he did really well this
is a great video this is really well
done I like these animation beat
openings have they done one for Avengers
Marvel would the my hero academia any of
them I bet if we search that well good
there's something I thought I came up
with the haunting of mill house and
apparently they already did pictures of
it oh I mean like the exact photo I was
thinking that you do you arrived at it
in depend
direct marketing I thought of that
turned out it already existed but I
arrived at it independently as did I as
did many people and I also wrote Mowgli
legend of the jungle and I produce
Capote the one infamous the one Oh with
Toby Jones yeah
well guys make sure to subscribe to
forever red 3000 and shouts out to
Matthew Cronin who was really helping me
out a lot right now with this shout out
about a week ago he's like hey you know
I pledged here's that video request
because we have a top award request for
whatever video you requested was put up
on YouTube and then I you know gave a
reply asked him a couple questions told
them some things and I haven't heard
back from him in about a week
cuz you opened up too much so now I'm
like I don't know what to provide for
your shoutout so here's how I'm gonna do
alright this is my go-to I'm gonna show
you some behind the scenes
Cronan name meaning this is where you
get so much to work with it's an Irish
surname okay comes from the Irish word
Kron meaning saffron colored ooh
they've been prominent this doesn't help
at all what the hell is Matthew name
meaning gift of Yahweh we've had other
people who named Matthew any of these
local disciple names or you know let's
just try the YouTube we can do
Cronenberg we could do a Cronenberg
thing that doesn't make sense his name's
Cronin okay let's just do youtubers you
know shout out hey Matthew thanks so
much for being part of our patreon page
which means a lot we couldn't do
anything any of this stuff so thank you
so much buddy I love you so much you
mean the world to me you're my favorite
thing in the whole world I have feelings
for you strong passionate hardcore
feelings I want up sometimes I look at
you while you're sleeping at night from
outside alright we're done